[Musique]
en juillet 2022 un ministre indien a été
hospitalisé après avoir bu l'eau d'un
fleuve il voulait en prouver la pureté
il a bu l'eau du Gange dans son verre
plus d'un million de bactéries fécales
heureusement avec la médecine moderne il
a survécu mais dans quelques années ça
guérison sera impossible car dans 27 ans
l'humanité va connaître sa plus grande
pandémie lentilles biorésistance l'OMS
prévoit qu'en 2050 10 millions de
personnes en mourront chaque année alors
on vous explique comment survivre à la
catastrophe qui vient pourquoi les
médicaments ne marcheront plus en 2050
en 1800 une infection bactérienne et
vous risquez la mort faute de traitement
une tuberculose c'était Game Over
heureusement on a plein de médicaments
aujourd'hui ça devrait aller mieux non
pas vraiment les bactéries sont toujours
la deuxième cause de décès dans le monde
et pas par manque de traitement au
contraire c'est parce qu'on en utilise
trop petit à petit les bactéries ont
développé une résistance aux
antibiotiques aux médicaments censé les
traiter regardez cette expérience
d'Arbor on ne met aucun produit sur les
bords et on augmente petit à petit
jusqu'à avoir 1000 fois la dose létale
pour une bactérie c'est effrayant en
quelques jours elles atteignent le
centre avec plusieurs points de mutation
à chaque fois elles sont devenues
résistantes aux antibiotiques faut dire
que dans l'histoire on les a utilisés
n'importe comment une petite grippe
prend des antibiots qui sert à rien
puisque ça tue les bactéries pas les
virus et même si tu as une vraie
infection bactérienne tu fais peut-être
partie des gens qui arrêtent leur
traitement dès que ça va un peu mieux
sauf que c'est la pire chose à faire tu
as encore des bactéries dans ton corps
celles qui ont réussi à survivre au
début du traitement et là tu vas les
donner à quelqu'un d'autre qui devra
prendre plus que ta dose pour guérir le
pire étant que 40% des médicaments non
utilisés finissent jeter n'importe où
les toilettes elle passe aux rivières ce
qui crée des bactéries mutagènes
surpuissante celle qui détruira
l'humanité peut être déjà là à attendre
dans un petit ruisseau du Loir-et-Cher
le pire c'est qu'on a découvert que ces
bactéries étaient capables de transférer
leur antibiorésistance à leurs voisines
on appelle ça transfert horizontal de
Gênes c'était effrayant jour après jour
elle se renforce et on ne peut plus les
arrêter sauf peut-être les
bactériophages chevront-ils l'humanité
au fond de vos toilettes se déroulent le
plus grande massacre de l'histoire des
millions de bactéries sont tués par ces
monstres les bactériophages comme des
aliens ils pondent leur matériel
génétique dans le corps de leur victime
des bébés bactériaux fachent multiplient
et la dévore de l'intérieur vous l'aurez
compris ce sont des virus mais des virus
inoffensifs pour l'homme n'infectant que
les bactéries malheureusement la guerre
n'est pas gagnée le premier problème des
bactériophages c'est leur manque de
mobilité ils ne peuvent pas bouger seul
ils ont besoin d'un support s'il ne
trouve personne infectées ils se font
détruire par l'environnement leur
deuxième problème c'est que les
bactéries se multiplient bien plus
rapidement évoluant constamment quand
elle se divise les nouvelles cellules
peuvent présenter des mutations
certaines les rendant invisibles aux
yeux des bactériophages la bactérie va
alors mieux survivre et transférer sa
résistance prenons Escherichia coli la
fameuse bactérie qui a contaminé les
pizzas brittoni et tuer deux
laissez-leur se diviser pendant 48
heures avec bouffe infini à la fin des
deux jours leur masse sera supérieure à
celle de la Terre avec autant de copies
statistiquement c'est certain qu'il y
aura la bonne mutation heureusement les
bactériophages eux aussi évoluent une
vraie course à l'armement se joue
actuellement la science devrait les
aider à gagner mais elle ne le fait pas
et la raison est étonnante tout le monde
sait ce qui est un antibiotique mais
demandez à n'importe qui dans la rue ce
qui est la phagothérapie et il vous
regardera comme si vous étiez un vendeur
de pierre magique en fait c'est
l'utilisation des bactériophages de
façon thérapeutique les injectés dans
ton corps pour qu'il combattent les
bactéries dans les années 20 ça se
faisait énormément puis plus du tout
peut-être parce que ça ne marche pas
parce qu'il y a des effets secondaires
mortels non par simple conflit d'ego en
1917 Félix derel microbiologiste
français travaille sur l’épidémie de
dysenterie à Paris c'est là qu'il isole
pour la première fois des bactériophages
capables de guérir les malades des rêves
visionnaires pensent qu'il s'agit d'un
virus à bactéries il avait
donc de l'Est on le sait aujourd'hui
l'humanité venait de faire une grossière
erreur la phagothérapie peut-elle encore
sauver l'humanité l'élaboratoires sont
en train de perdre la guerre
bactériologique des cons commercialisent
un nouvel antibiotique on appelle un an
il sert déjà plus à rien une résistance
est apparue et là on est au bout du
rouleau ça fait 35 ans qu'on a pas
découvert un nouveau type d'antibiotique
et c'est pas tout dans notre corps 50%
des cellules qui nous composent sont des
bactéries et de bonnes bactéries et
essentielles à notre fonctionnement nous
sommes pour ainsi dire des hybrides
entre elles et un humain malheureusement
quand vous avalez un antibiotique ça
fait pas dans le détail gentil pas
gentil bactéries c'est n'a pas le même
pour tout le monde vous tuez la moitié
de vous-même et même un peu plus parce
que même nos cellules humaines sont
empoisonnées vous voyez le cercle
vicieux on augmente les doses on
augmente l'agressivité des antibiotiques
on s'affaiblit pendant que l'ennemis se
renforce maintenant ne pas en prendre
c'est risquer la mort la solution
revenir à la phagothérapie mais comment
produire les bactériophage bon il suffit
de les chercher là où ils sont plus
nombreux les os usaient des toilettes là
où vous urinez vos médicaments et vos
bactéries antibiorésistantes dans ces
bouts s'ils sont développés leur super
prédateurs comprenez pourquoi les eaux
du Gange ont la réputation de guérir
certaines maladies elle regorge de
bactéries Fages et ils ont plein
d'avantages tu peux les spécialiser dans
la chasse d'un type précis de bactéries
il ne rentre pas dans nos cellules
humaines donc il ne les empoisonne pas
et puis ce sont des virus ils se
répliquent tout seul une seule dose
suffirait pour vous guérir beaucoup plus
pratique que de prendre deux comprimés
par jour pendant deux semaines
malheureusement vous en doutez rien
n'est miraculeux dans ce monde et les
bactériophages ont aussi leur défaut
déjà ils s'adapte lentement aux
mutations des bactéries et comme on l'a
vu elles sont capables d'inventer des
stratégies de dissimulation de se rendre
invisible à leur prédateurs or c'est le
deuxième problème il faut vous injecter
le bon bactériophage qui va s'attaquer
précisément à la bonne bactérie or les
analyses pour l'identifier prennent du
temps et coup vous êtes malade vous avez
besoin d'un traitement rapide les
antibiotiques au moins on perd pas de
temps ça tue tout le monde sans parler
du nombre de bactériophages différents
que les industriels devraient produire
pratiquement un parti de bactéries c'est
juste parental voire même logistiquement
pas réalisable et comme s'il y avait pas
cette problème il faut vous faire une
piqûre donc aller à l'hôpital ou appeler
un soignant c'est plus long plus cher
moins pratique qu'un comprimé pourquoi
ne pas faire des bactériophages en
pilule bah déjà est-ce qu'elles vont
survivre à l'air libre et surtout à
l'acide de l'estomac les problèmes sont
pas finis une fois les bactériophages
dans votre corps votre système
immunitaire pourrait les reconnaître
comme des ennemis ce qui est aggraverait
l'infection coup de grâce on l'a vu avec
le covid c'est difficile de faire
accepter aux gens de se faire injecter
des choses qu'il ne comprennent pas on
parlait pourtant juste d'une petite
bille de gras avec un morceau d'ARN
imaginez maintenant les faire accepter
un virus mutant qui ressemble à ça mais
soyons optimistes des solutions vont
émerger on pourrait créer des cocktails
de pour viser plusieurs infections en un
seul médicament on pourrait aussi
baisser l'acidité de l'estomac quand on
a besoin d'en prendre en pilule gardons
espoir les bactériophages sont déjà
utilisés dans d'autres domaines comme
l'agronomie pour stériliser les aliments
et les cultures en recherche pour
découvrir de nouvelles techniques
d'édition de génome espérons juste que
cette fois les petites luttes politiques
et économiques ne ruineront pas le
dernier espoir de l'humanité
[Musique]